assalamu alaikum
so we're with Robert Davila
how are you brother you're on the Dean
show yeah did you ever hear the Dean
show yeah have you want to yeah i do
what's a lot masha'Allah
so so we were talking about about your
amazing story you had so much of people
that were really amazed by some of the
things that you you went through and
then to all of that you ended up not
some years ago accepting Islam you got
you got in an accident where you got
paralyzed from your neck down is that
correct yeah yes and then you were you
were sharing you were sharing with me a
little while ago how you your mother was
Unitarian Christian then to kind of fill
us in on what we were talking about and
vaguely is being you would pray directly
to God to the Creator God Almighty yes
without anybody in the middle
no no incision no intercessor in the
middle just directly to God the Creator
is in okay I was a Unitarian but she
uh-huh she's a Unitarian Christian yeah
so this was back in early 2011 you
accepted Islam yeah I'd go grace
so you came from from from a staunch
Christian Unitarian Christian background
yeah we were okay when I was a kid I did
more thing
and only where my friends took me to oh
gosh really call that it's Kanaka okay
in school a youth group yes yeah as a
kid I thought it was just so dumb
nothing in it and so I quit really on
there
I waited once twice and the god just
wanted to hang out uh-huh if we eating
deeds anything he just they kind of suck
really evil English you're talking about
this crate there was a crib that was the
Christian youth group you're talking
about yeah yeah and the guy there was
they the guy interested in being friends
with us being was teaching us about
faith or anything about basic things you
know so I got mad and long as a wooden
was the longest time I said it was it is
you said you were atheist for a long
time for the longest time yes all
through God all through high school and
whatnot and it was until I got airline
that I started praying and whatnot so
did you feel that you did you become or
you called yourself an atheist because
you didn't have the answers that you
were looking for
yeah I'm pretty much pretty much yeah
what were some of the questions that you
had like
like the meaning of life the meaning
come from why are you here like Oh
everyone was there with something and
asked no to me serious I mean those are
serious questions that many people are
not reflecting upon meaning of life
what's the purpose of life why am I here
where am I going when I die I mean those
are just intelligent questions you were
far more intelligent than many of the
people out there because you were asking
the right questions thank you
yeah and I used to be I used to be
scared to die and whatnot but no longer
I was scared because I know why I know
my way and whatnot tell us about this
there was a friend of yours who had this
ambulant that he passed he passed away
before you and then someone brought his
amulet crucifix to you
yeah his sister Dean actually he had a
piano crucifix on the wall and he would
always have okay a fencer would always
talk about him but they would never
speak to me they'll never understand why
and had liver cancer or cirrhosis which
is pretty much clear cancer and on the
day of his surgery he got a donor and on
the day of surgery he died months ago
and his sister games that were him and
for the longest time I never knew what
it was about it and okay
I had the crucifix on the wall
and one day in our inner dream mommy
came to me and said this is just a man
take this down and you know if it was
God it would eat or what other ways you
do and whatnot and from there I woke up
and I immediately accepted Islam Wow so
that that was you're saying that Prophet
Muhammad came to you in a dream you had
this cruise you had this crucifixion
there and something along the lines of
that God didn't send say that say that
again how was it that Jesus wasn't God
that God didn't send messengers to be
worshipped or Toni worship God the
Creator how something like that yeah
uh-huh I mean that's amazing
let's go ahead I wish for a speech I
wish my speech was never affected I can
talk in better
you just had you also just had a stroke
right I think I did yeah it was because
some months ago I couldn't speak clearly
but now my speech is like so in indeed
it's infuriating
let's continue where you are talking
about the dream so you had a dream all
this was leading up you were you you had
some friends who are Muslim at that time
and they were kind of answering your
questions you had your friend that died
you had yourself looking for answers in
life and then the dream happens yes so
how did you take that after the dream
after you debt how did how did you you
came to know that this was did anyone
tell you that this was Prophet Mohammed
and your dream
no in a song I did a lot of the the I
spoke to brothers from Egypt and a
brother a brother from England for a
while in the longest time and there is
anything you never said anything for the
longest time yes how did how did they
determine or how did you determine and
find out that this was Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him can you dream well I
was told that's what you were told after
you gave him the description to two
people more knowledgeable oh no I I knew
in my I knew in my heart that it was him
in the dream but I didn't know I just
thought it would be no I spoke to other
Oh after you spoke to other Muslims and
they said this was Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him yes and pretty much in
the dream summarizing he was telling you
not to worship that crucifixion or not
to worship Jesus but just to worship the
god of Jesus to worship the One God yes
this was this was the main message of
that dream yes sir that makes sense
because that's that pure monotheism that
came throughout history throughout time
they got almighty out of his love he
sent messengers he sent these prophets
to call people to worship one and only
one God and to do good deeds to be
morally upright this is that same
message that's been there since the
beginning and did that make sense to you
it was yes it made Lawson so it's okay
there was a questionnaire on my own that
I found online and all of the answers I
entered were it said if you answer these
questions with these answers you are a
Muslim and you should accept Islam
and that was in early 2011 and all along
as I was contemplating and then finally
f is a dream accepted as long and then I
focus on rings and they told me go ahead
to go ahead and to take the Shahada yes
yeah so that was in 2011 now we're in
2020 going on 21
and you're still a Muslim you're still
in Islam yes sir yes sir masha'Allah and
I'm very delighted and happy to meet you
yeah thank you
yeah so you've uh you've actually
memorized a lot of Quran also I heard
you're not judging masha'Allah this is
great how do you for people who are out
there you know taking life for granted
people who are out there ungrateful for
many of the simple things in life that
now taking things for granted not being
grateful for many of the gifts what
message do you have for them don't give
up and always rely on God always rely on
God yes because even you ain't be super
losing and there's always something
worse there you may be stripped to
something but there's always something
worse
yes yeah that reminds me of the hadith
where the Prophet Muhammad SAW of Salaam
he said that always look to those who
have less and they love you
yeah because now you actually in a sense
somewhat someone can have all the money
and all of the material things but at
the end their heart is not in a state
like where your hearts at where you
finally found the purpose of life why
you've been created now at the end a
person dies in that state
you know without the guidance of their
creator and they all they did was
worship money and power and fame that's
that's a worse place to be in in life it
is no and I felt because in the place I
was before was here there was a you guys
that were much much worse do me the way
they were they were what they were what
they were much worse off than I ended
all guys that were there weren't there
at the at the nursing home yes they were
worse than you yes they were
yeah it was in Oakland they were they
were worse than me and it gave me hope
but really all of them do was spin days
ring you would spend days praying still
keeping your salat huh yeah masha'Allah
okay I tried before but I couldn't
because my I had to take pills and their
water or I couldn't really fast but I
still do groans you still observe
Ramadan yes masha'Allah this is this is
amazing so you were you are also telling
me about your your family some of them
because they got caught up with much of
the media hype and misinformation they
didn't take so well to you accepting
Islam because they were thinking that oh
now a lot of the negative things that
are associated terrorism and all this
other nonsense that's a trick that's
associated with Islam have to have they
kind of cooled off yet well yeah but
only because I
only because I told certain people the
people always hostess do that I was no
longer it was them I had yeah or they
would never see me again
Oh so that would that was there some of
the family members there is yeah I see
mainly my father and my sister uh-huh
yeah so how's your relationship with
them now now it was very much better
yeah but I was in 81 for months because
of the warning because of the the
quarantine you know yeah they won't let
nobody come visit no no nobody can come
visit huh no not since uh March the
middle March
yeah and it's polite dude Eli huh
because you see was it maybe on Friday
we had to take it away yeah but didn't
bother me I had the camera and stuck of
mine movie work yeah I heard the story
also that one day you were reciting some
Quran and then someone who was passing
by your room heard you and they were
very shocked and surprised and then a
conversation began began that was with
with a Muslim can you tell us about that
do you recollect that the guy was
program he was from where everything
Africa so you're you're there he that
was the last place he expected to and
the last person he expected to find
reciting Quran yeah yeah he was very
surprised
I wish I heard this thing yeah amazing
is there someone to one story that a new
one all the gone wrong and I will need
to straighten it out
wouldn't ya so now's your chance go
ahead tell me if anything anything that
you want to share with us you can go
ahead anything that that you've you felt
was very important
well okay I'm not a farmer know what nor
did I have a genetic disease okay so you
weren't a farmer or didn't have a
genetic disease no but geez we go again
to be sure you want I would have to
watch his video again to be sure what he
said yeah so but but correct thing was
that you actually had a hat you had an
accident yes it was a car accident
yes and then you broke your neck well
okay I didn't see one right you what
we're like my my cranium the attachment
was fine
yes it was putting it back together that
realized me mm-hmm
putting it back together yes yeah
because I had to wear halo were uh let
me see three or four months and it was
man it was crazy
I remember all of the room was four to
three weeks I was crying and whatnot and
finally I I was one day praying and
crying and I figured you know I'm not
getting any better and people are just
gonna dislike me more if I'm bitter so
don't be bitter
don't be bitter so frenetic I've nothing
there's so many people they're bringing
two there are and I you know I try to
tell you really but nobody yeah look to
those who have less I mean don't be
bitter you talked about that as to
advice what other advice before we close
would you like to give to the world
hmm from all your experience now and
mm-hmm just that uh you know makes the
most the way you can and always always
were that no matter what you're just
eating and you are going to die so live
your life and let me see treat others
the way you would want to be chained to
yourself I'll be kind to others be a
good human being
and never lose hope and God Almighty the
creator yeah
yes Algrim yeah you know that you know
there's a beautiful statement from the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him that once a person is dipped in
paradise just for a second then they'll
ask have you seen any hardships in this
life
I'm sure you've heard have you heard of
this hadith yes yeah oh yeah
so Islam gives so much optimism and hope
because this life is short is transitory
and there's something better waiting for
us and when finally you're exposed to
that then all all of all of the things
of joy and happiness and everything will
just overtake a person and he'll forget
about or she'll forget about all of the
drama pain and all of the hardships that
they went through in this life and may
god almighty allah the creator of
heavens and earth reunite us in jena and
paradise it an easy life and if i'm ever
you're in texas if I'm ever in Texas and
sha Allah we can meet in person sometime
okay yes it's all inshallah thank you
brother thank you for sharing that with
us may Allah bless you and reward you
chuckle hi assalamualaikum table cut
[Music]
you know
[Music]